hello glad to be here welcome to this
talk on using high performance data
processing in Python specifically we're
going to be applying that to doing some
algorithmic trading just a little bit
about myself beforehand I'm a software
engineer I work for a new york-based
algorithmic trading firm so what we do
is we build mathematical models to
predict the prices the prices of stocks
and then try and build automated trading
algorithms on top of that what I do is I
build our scalable data processing
infrastructure so we use hundreds of
data sets to try and predict stock
prices and we need easy and fast ways to
ingest all these different data sets and
different shapes and sizes I know I'm
also responsible for building the
real-time trading systems that actually
execute our trades on the market when
our models have decided what to trade so
I'm primarily a Python a C++ developer
I'm trying to remove that C++ part and
replace it with rust because C++ is a
pain in the ass to use but anyway about
this talk so as we all know - is a
hugely popular tool for data analysis
that's the whole point of this
conference for example JetBrains survey
last year showed that data analysis is
now as popular as web development in
python so half of all use cases in
python are now data science which is a
very different landscape to what it was
say eight or ten years ago
and why is this the case so as many of
you know is because it's suitable for
research its high-level and easy to use
doesn't require advanced programming
knowledge and enables researchers to
write very complex things very quickly
in each rate and ideas very quickly but
unlike a lot of its competitors like
MATLAB for example it's also a
general-purpose language that's useful
outside of data science this means that
it's you can just take your code from
research and easily with very little
effort slot it into a production system
rather than have to re-implement
everything from that lab in Python for
example so that's the piping strength is
that it's suitable for both use cases
you can iterate and ideas quickly and
research but you can also take those
ideas and deploy them in real life
systems with very little if any extra
effort so the issue is python is slow or
at least pure python - is not meant to
be a fast language it's meant to be an
easy high-level easy to use language any
benchmark that you that you actually do
against faster languages like C or C++
ipython will always lose out which means
actually is bad for
HP up - because it means that you're
iterating very slowly because all the
calculations you're doing at taking
hundreds of times longer and it's
actually bad for production because you
can't run time sensitive data processing
tasks without actually having to go with
a faster language so the solution is to
use PI pythons data processing ecosystem
what we're going to focus on here is
numpy I know many of you have already
used numpy but many of you might not
know how it actually works internally
and why it is so fast which is the
purpose of this talk and as many of you
know Putnam PI is the heart of
scientific computing in Python stores
and operates on C structures to avoid
the slowness that Python has and it's
the foundation of a lot of packages like
numpy pandas and so on which all you all
use on a daily basis so I'll focus is to
show how to use numpy to process
numerical data explore how numpy uses
vectorization to dramatically boost
performance or keeping the productivity
that python gives us we're gonna be
building an algorithmic trading strategy
using stock pricing data we're gonna be
processing that stock pricing data in
pure Python speeding it up using the
apply and vectorization and then
speeding up even more using another tool
called number the final optimized
solution will be almost two thousand
times faster than the original pure
Python implementation so let's do it
let's make some cash we're tired of
working for the man we're tired of
slaving away in a company as like as two
corporate software developer so we've
decided we're gonna use our skills to
build an automated trading strategy and
make ourselves a lot of money the data
we're going to use is a publicly
available data set of 7,000 plus US
stocks this is pricing data for these
stocks every day from 1962 to 2017 this
data set is just a collection of CSV
files where each CSV file represents the
full pricing history of a single stock
so one of these files for example the
one for Apple AAPL
contains two columns the date and then
close which is the price of that stock
at the close of the market on that date
it's a very simple data set and if you
plotted one of these CSV files you'd get
what you'd expect a stock chart and
graph and as of all stocks have mostly
increased a lot over the past 20 years
you get this massive jump at the end so
the data set is very small this data
sets only a gigabyte in size that's not
very big at all so why is this going to
take so long to process oh it's because
we're going to be doing some very
complicated calculations
that data so our goal is to build a
program that generates a list of trades
to make so every day our program will
take pricing data historical pricing
data and from before that day and then
generate a single trade list which is
the buy and sell orders to sent to the
market disclaimer the strategy were
about to do is extremely basic this
would have this worked actually did work
in the 90s and early noughties this
won't work anymore because everyone is
doing algorithmic trading so you need to
be a lot more complicated than what
we're about to do but the good news is
that this strategy does reflect the
high-level structure of how real trading
strategies actually work so the type of
trading strategies we run this is the
type of scripture that we actually use
so this strategy that we're gonna use
leverages two fundamental behaviors
about stock prices the first is that
prices revert to the mean now you can
imagine a time series where a time
series particularly ones like the stock
prices are very noisy so you get this
like up-and-down notion but then it's
jittering around some kind of general
trend so even if a stock is generally
going up it's gonna be bouncing around
that sort of general upward trend so for
example you v average might be this
straight line over time but the actual
real price is jumping up and down like
on either side of that moving average so
in other words if a price drops below
the moving average we expect it to
revert back to the moving average
eventually because of this whole notion
of it reverting to the mean over a
period of time so if we consider the
stocks of returns which is the change in
price not the the absolute price for
example we can calculate that by taking
the price of a stock today subtracting
it from the price yesterday and if we
look at this graph which is two weeks
worth of pricing data or returns data
for Apple this graph represents the
changes in the price of the Apple stock
so you see it drops two dollars and then
increases two dollars and so on and so
forth that orange line is the moving
average of the change so what you can
see is that it's generally zero this
particular one it's slightly below zero
but what this means is that often you're
just kind of bouncing around a mean
because if you go down to dollars you
inevitably end up coming back to dollars
or close to it because of this moving
average being zero so a mean reversion
trading strategy is basically you buy in
a stock when it's returns exceed a
certain threshold away from the moving
average so as an example suppose of
$90,000 to trade with suppose our
threshold is $1 so when the price change
is greater than $1 away from the mean
from the moving average then we decide
to buy the stock but we buy the stock
because we expect it will revert back to
the mean which means that it will go up
in price again so we're buying low and
selling high so if we just always make
sure when we buy these stocks we sell to
just exactly one day regardless of what
happens then we do something like this
the next day we sell and because the
prices reverted back to the mean we've
made money and repeat this process every
single time we go beyond the threshold
and we eventually get these sequence of
trade pairs so these buy and sell pairs
some of them make money some of them
don't the key here is that you make more
right trades and wrong ones
so you've guessed that is reverted back
to the mean more than you've incorrectly
guessed that and then you make money so
in this case and there's two weeks you
made a two percent return of investment
not bad but the problem is the price
might not actually revert back to the
mean so there's this opposing notion of
momentum where a price might increase
incite increase in increase and then
keep increasing even accelerating rates
so rather than going up and then going
back down it's actually rallying and
it's suddenly going very very high and
if we try it all very very low and if we
try and use mean reversion we'll lose
money because we buy low thinking is
going to increase again and then it
doesn't so we sadly even lower so we
just keep losing and losing money so we
don't want to do this we want to avoid
trading during these momentum phases so
we leverage the second behavior of
stocks which is as stocks are correlated
so as an example if we plot the returns
of Apple the change in price of Apple
and Amazon you see that these time
series are very similar they're both big
tech companies
so they're both correlate well very well
with each other when one moves the other
one tends to move similarly Apple is
actually correlated with the whole US
stock market so if you take the top 500
US stocks whenever it moves Apple tends
to move as well sounds pretty obvious I
know but this is actually a very
powerful useful piece of information
that we can use to avoid trading join
his momentum phases so we use stock
correlations to detect these phases and
only use mean reversion when we think
the
docks are hovering around the same price
and aren't fundamentally going up or
down over long periods of time so
basically what this means is we take
these for all 7,000 stocks that we're
going to trade we're gonna take the
returns of that stock the historical
returns we're going to combine it with
the correlations that that stock has
with all the other stocks all over 7,000
stocks and then we're gonna merge this
into a time series called the
unexplained stock returns and then we
apply mean reversion to this adjusted
return time series now the oil explained
stock returns represent the movements
and the stock price that we can't
explain by over market movements for
example if Apple decreases in price but
other tech companies don't decrease in
price so there's not this general market
downturn we can't explain the decrease
in price we don't think there's a real
reason that the price is actually
fundamentally decreased so we assume
that it's noise and it's gonna revert
back to the mean and will go back up
again so since only Apple has decreased
for all of its correlated stocks haven't
decreased we assume mean reversion buy
and then sell the next day this is the
hardest step very very hard in fact this
is by far where all the magic comes in
in terms of making money the most basic
solution you could do is using PCA and
linear regression to perform this
process called residual ization which
generates that unexplained stock returns
time series for all of these 7000 stocks
we don't have time to go into detail on
how exactly these work here just
remember that we are using this
technique to generate these unexplained
returns and actually this requires a lot
of calculations so if we actually try
and implement this in a pure Python
program what we want to do is we want to
run a simulation where every weekday
just before the US stock market closes
we calculate the stocks daily returns
for the past year we calculate the
correlation of every single one of those
stocks with every other stocks that's
about 7,000 squared correlations and
then we use the correlations and returns
to do this to get this unexplained stock
returns by instead side will buy and
sell orders to make execute the buy and
sell orders and then wait for exactly
one day we keeping this very simple we
wait for just one day and then we get
rid of the stocks that we bought we
sellable so we get to simulate how much
money we make and we can use the pricing
data that we already have to do this our
range is going to be 1990 to 2000
team so 2017 is whether this data ends
just going to leave it at that I'm gonna
write the strategy and pure Python don't
have to go to the implementation but
essentially just it's pure - it's using
various built-in Python C routines but
necessary but it's not using any kind of
numpy or any data processing library on
top of just using Bill and Python stuff
so the result is we actually make a lot
of money to begin with so from 1990 to
2001 we make this this plot is the
cumulative returns so overall from if we
put in say a million at the beginning
we're making about 60% to that million
which isn't bad so that's pretty good
but as 2001 onward Technica's we all we
actually start to lose money so what's
happened here is that over people in the
market at this time have actually
started building way more sophisticated
algorithms than this so back in the
nineties no one was really doing this
type of algorithmic trading or at least
at the same scale that they do now so it
was easy to kind of game the system and
make a lot of money with very simple
algorithms whereas now it's not as
always happened is we're competing
against even smarter algorithms from
2001 onwards so we're actually losing
money and that sucks you know that's
that's not ideal this stuff is hard so
you're not expected to actually succeed
first time around but the real kicker
here is that if I actually ran this
using that pure Python program if I ran
the full simulation I would have
actually had to wait three years to get
the resource that is how slow that pure
Python implementation was so I actually
ran it on just a small subset and then
just calculated from there because each
days around same hour computation so
this is obviously a huge problem like
obviously three years is ridiculous but
even if this simulation took four days
that would still be too long strategies
or any kind of building any type of
model requires massive amounts of tuning
and experimentation and these
simulations need to run fast hours not
years and so what went wrong
well three steps are computationally
heavy we have this return step that
calculates the stocks daily returns for
the past year correlation which
calculates the correlation between all
those returns and then the decision step
which uses PCA in linear regression to
perform that residual ization process I
talked about earlier now to put it in
concrete terms I calculated by hand the
amount of floating-point operations I
would actually be required and to do the
full simulation
the return step is not that much but
there's correlation of decision steps
are truly huge and this is because a lot
of the music I went squared of n cubed
algorithms and so the total operations
is about 200 million which is a lot so
when we break this down we see that the
return step takes half a day and then
the correlation decision steps are
really where it starts to slow down now
I'm not gonna go into too much detail
and why python is so slow but the
primary reasons are its dynamically
typed which means every single
floating-point operation you do requires
probably a dozen more operations because
it doesn't know the types in advance
it's interpreted not compiled which
means that the compiler can optimize
anything in advance and it has
fragmented memory access because the
lists in Python store heterogeneous
types they can contain different types
in the same list which means it's
actually a list of pointers so you have
loads of memory indirection and you're
kind of like throttling in the cache
basically so how can we do better
and this is when dump pie comes in so
they an umpire is the fundamental
package for high-performance computing a
pie for number crunching there are lot
of other libraries as well but none pi
tends to be the one that she's the most
sure again as you're aware and really
the key reason why it ends up being so
much faster than people - is because it
has this multi-dimensional array object
that stores everything in continuous
memory buffers and then it has heavily
optimized C routines to operate on those
buffers on the C level
avoiding any Python code whatsoever so
if we look at this ND array class this
is a class that represents any n
dimensional array it's a fixed size
elements must be the same type which
simplifies on optimizers a lot of things
so to give you an example if we call m
Peter a range to generate this array of
nine elements what it actually looks
like in memory is this so we have this
memory buffer and then we have a bunch
of metadata fields that actually
describe how tell numpy how to navigate
the memory buffer to get the data it
needs so this memory block is just a
block of nine float64 the shape
parameter tells you the size of the
array or the size of the data in the
buffer and the stride parameter tells
you how long how how many bytes to move
along the buffer to get to the next
element and actually these shapes and
Strides parameters allow you to do very
interesting things for example just
calling a reshape to change this nine
sized array into a free by free matrix
requires no copies it's actually just
changing the shape and Strides
parameters what's happening is it just
changes shape to three three changes
tries to twenty-four eight to say move
to the next row by moving twenty four by
T's in this flat memory buffer and then
move a bike's eight bytes to get to the
next column in that particular row so
you can do loads of things that you can
slice out particular dimensions you can
you know you can sort of iterate every
two rows or whatever and the key thing
here is when you're doing all these
types of operations these reshaping and
slicing operations create a view they
don't actually copy the data which in
this example doesn't matter but if
you've got an array of you know nine
billion floating-point numbers all this
starts to add up so the performance
benefit is saw that data is stored
contiguously so there's no memory
overhead you have cache locality because
everything's packed
you know compactly put together there's
no copies for common operations and
again these memory buffers that are
stored it basically in the sea level in
numpy there's very fast numpy operation
so operating on those but i even
touching the Python level so it's a
basic benchmark I'm adding 10 million
numbers if we use a list comprehension
to add to two different ten million
number arrays in pure Python and then in
numpy we create two numpy arrays we can
I have a loop through the food eater
right through the arrays and then just
one by one calculate the resort or we
can just use an umpire's built in
addition operator and we see this as the
timings we get and this is on just that
map book that I have so one second for
Python numpy with the looping takes 3.4
seconds and then the built-in on PI X
naught point naught 3 so the built-in
operator is 36 times faster now what's
interesting here this isn't surprising
than pi is obviously faster but what's
interesting is that the numpy with the
loop is slower in fact there's almost
four times slower than the pure pipe
implementation and this is because when
you're explicitly looping over numpy
arrays you've basically lost all the
benefit of actually using them pi or any
of these libraries in the first place so
if you imagine that this for loop every
single time we were retrieving an
element from one of these numpy arrays
we're going into the sea level we're
going into that memory buffer and over
copying out as a pipe in integer in the
PI foot level so we're actually doing 3
copies for every iteration there and if
it's written over 10 million numbers
that's 30 million copies plus you
all the function call overheads of
calling gas item on the numpy raise
every single time now the real real way
to use numpy in these types of libraries
is to try and push every all the
computation and all the looping into the
numpy level so here we have C equals a
plus 1 a plus B sorry and that's just
one function call in Python and
everything else is run in the numpy
layer and that means you don't have any
you're removing any potential Python
overhead so the key here is you keep it
in the umpire you don't loop through
these arrays and you move the
computation to the native level where
possible so when we use numpy for the
trading simulation just to give you a
recap these are the three steps that
were computationally heavy in the
simulation if we focus on the first step
we don't have time to cover how numpy is
using the second then the second or
third steps this first step is quite
simple all we're trying to do is
calculate the stalks returns for the
past year now the returns here that
we're using are normalized so we're
using the percentage return this is
today's price minus yesterday's price
over yesterday's price so you get the
percentage change from date from each
day what the price of each stock is so
as an example in Apple if we wanted to
calculate the returns on the second of
August we simply say 155 minus 1 for 8
which is the price on the previous day
divide it by 1 for 8 and you get 4 point
7 so the return is 4 point 7 it's
increased by 4 point 7 so if you bought
it the day before and then sold it the
next day you would have made 4 point 7
profit out of it so we need to calculate
this return for all stocks on all days
we could use a nested for loop for stock
in stocks for day in all the dates that
we want to calculate the returns for but
of course as we've established that's
slow lots of copies and slow operations
are being run in Python code so instead
what we're going to do is use numpy to
compute these returns we're gonna pack
all the stock prices for all the dates
in one compact matrix and then we're
going to perform bulk operations on this
matrix so if you imagine this dot price
matrix where one dimension is the stocks
and the other dimension is the price is
the date then what we want to do is take
this matrix of prices and dates Nannes
where you don't have any pricing
information and you want to calculate as
a returns matrix where each cell
represents the change in price
from the previous day so essentially
what this means is to calculate this
cell this red cell on the right returns
matrix
we're just taking that same called the
same cell in the same in the pricing
matrix and the previous cell on the
previous date to compute it now again
instead of manually calculating each
cell with a for loop we're going to use
these book operations so we take our
prices matrix we shift it by moving all
the prices forward ones to get
yesterday's prices and then we look at
our returns formula and instead of
substituting each individual cell into
the formula we just substitute it with
each matrix so because to pricing matrix
- yesterday pricing matrix divided by
pricing matrix and then all the element
wise operations will happen in the C
level and that will give you back your
returns matrix and then unlike code for
this is incredibly simple you can this
is a really basic example but you can
take the pricing matrix is you can
initialize it as an array of all zeros
the shape is the number of dates in the
simulation by the number of stocks in
the simulation then you populates it
using the CSV files that I showed
earlier you compute yesterday's prices
with the shift prices matrix and then
you just run the returns formula on the
matrices so you see the key here is this
doesn't have a for loop and the previous
thing had a for loop that's really only
kind of all you need to know and by this
not having a for loop it means you're
avoiding any kind of - inefficiencies
and when we do this we change this from
462 minutes to 8 minutes
so we've actually arguably made the code
even more concise and simple anyway but
also we've just made it tons faster so
it's a 79 times speed-up now we can use
these steps to perform similar
optimizations on the correlation and
decision steps and when we look at that
we take it for three years to 2.8 days
because so it's free to the 90 times
faster just by using instead of Python
for loops using numpy race the key here
is the reason implies something faster
is that there's no extra memory overhead
there's minimal copying it's cache
friendly and again all these operations
are executed in compiled code so by
expressing data in the svet vector
matrix form you open up a whole new
world of optimizations and this is
essentially called vectorization or at
least in Python world this is called
vectorization
so the
vectorization in python is the process
of rewriting your code to express all
the calculations in a ray matrix form so
you can utilize all of these C libraries
and this is often easy to do like an in
this example with the returns matrix it
was very easy to just rewrite it using
numpy but it's not always you might need
to completely redesign your algorithms
in order to vectorize them and it's
actually actually non-trivial to do so
and also not all our algorithms are
actually vectorizable some of them
inherently need to depend on the states
on like a previous loop iteration in
which case you can't back to rise so
here we see this is the times that we
currently have now after applying numpy
the decision step is still really slow
so this is still significantly slower
than the others and this is because
there's some non vectorizable components
in this particular step and this is what
number comes in so the problem we have
is an all algorithms effect arise abort
and we still have some ore in
vectorizable code that we haven't
optimizing is running in pure Python the
solution is to compile non vectorizable
Python code to native machine
instructions and we can do that using
number so number basically it just
allows you to annotate Python functions
say compile this as native machine code
and it will do so for you automatically
so if we consider this example let's
just assume that pythons built in some
function doesn't exist for the purposes
of demonstration but suppose what if
there's some an array and you just had a
function to do so you have an array you
have a result value and you're just
iterating through and adding all the
numbers together now if you just import
the JIT decorator from number decorate
the function with JIT know Python equals
true telling' number you must compile
this as native machine code and if you
cannot raise an exception we get this
difference so it's one point seven
seconds in Python and not quite not a
lot of six five seconds in number so you
get a two years or 70 times speed-up
just by adding address now number needs
to know the types in the function in
order to know what types to use in the
native compiled machine code because
compiled code the types have to be
static they have to be known in advance
so it uses the types of the first
invocation of the are of the function in
order to determine what the types will
be you can also explicitly specify them
so here you can say well JIT the
function but make sure that the return
value is an in 64
and then the input array is an array of
in 64's the key here is that this is not
magic it's cool that we can increase
this one function by terms of 17 times
but you're really restricted in what you
can actually do in these routines so as
soon as you put no pipe in equals true
in that decorator it will raise an
exception if it cannot compile it to
machine code and that means actually you
can't you're very limited in the types
of Python features you can use so you
can't just import any Python library and
just use it magically you can't do some
of the crazier more things that you
would generally do in like a dynamically
typed language it's really only intended
for optimizing these compete computer
heavy functions so if you have these
small functions that where you've got
really hot loops they're really heavy
loops out iterating like a billion two
billion times or something like that
it's really meant for those so it's not
gonna help you can I just do act JIT on
everything and expect it to be faster so
when we use this for the trading
simulation we add so we're adding at JIT
no Pythian equals true to all the
functions that do any kind of
computation and just in case we're
explicitly specifying the types because
sometimes numbers type numbers type
inference can be a bit iffy we get this
so we're taking from 2.8 days to not 0.5
eight days so now it's taking roughly
about half a day and with the speed-up
from the original field python
implementation is 1900 so you see on the
steps that the returns and correlation
step are haven't changed they haven't
you got any faster and that's because
they were already or they're already
running in native machine code because
we're just running Python routines from
all vex it was all vectorized code that
was running in dumb pi whereas this
decision step had some unvectorized
stuff that was running in pure Python so
by adding JIT there we actually got some
benefit and so you see here we've gone
from two point six seven six one sorry
to not point three seven so that the
point is in a nutshell when you're doing
this type of heavy computation in Python
trying use vectorizing on pi code where
possible it will probably be faster than
even using number for example if you
actually just try and express everything
in vector matrix form but often you
can't either because it's very difficult
to do so and you know there's there's
business limitations in terms of
development time or you just can't
because it's an inherently an
unvectorized well algorithm you fall
back to number so the final timings is
we a pill pipe implementation started
ridiculous was ridiculous
this slow and this is a logarithmic plot
by the way hence why they even seem
remotely close at all and when we
vectorized we got most of the way there
so when we used numpy where possible we
got most of the way there and we very
very much sped this up but there was
still lots of code that wasn't optimized
and so we use number to fill in the gaps
where we couldn't vectorize so we've
taken it for three years to 14 hours and
this is just running on a single MacBook
Pro so yeah that is pretty much the talk
just to summarize - is great for
research but I'll I'll the box - is to
slow the increasing demands for faster
real-time data processing processing
large volumes of data or training
complex models and you can't really use
standard Python first because it's too
slow it's bad for research and it's bad
for production but you can still use
Python of course by using the scientific
computing packages the key is knowing
how to use them correctly I've seen a
lot of researchers in alpha and for
example who aren't as familiar with how
numpy actually works and they'll use
numpy just thinking is going to speed
things up and actually it makes things
slower or doesn't help at all so it's
knowing what they're actually doing
under the hood and by doing so it's very
little work to actually use these tools
properly to get the speed ups you want
you keep all your computation in native
code by vectorizing using dumb PI and
then using number to optimize your
vectorizable code if that isn't enough
yes you can hamper analyze you could you
try and identify ways to share your data
you're split up were on different
machines on a computer but I kind of
urged people before they actually go too
slow let's try and paralyze actually
triangles using these tools like numpy
and number to optimize everything in one
single process first and see if that's
enough really all you're doing when you
kind of paralyzed to a cluster
immediately is just throwing the problem
over the water DevOps because as soon as
you paralyze using a cluster then you
have all the issues around
distributed system guarantees failover
there's all those types of things that
you need to deal with so suddenly
actually you're making the problem way
more complicated when you could have
actually just sped it up by just doing
number dodge it so just using the umpire
number alone can yield of time speed it
so I encourage you to try these types of
tools first and that is a talk thank you
very much
Oh link to the slides here and also if
I'll be through the drinks later so if
anyone wants to talk about anything
relate to talk to my Seng - this is just
the surface feel free to talk to me
later a happy dance for anything or just
contact me on Twitter or whatever else
thank you any questions
so number so actually so number any of
the normal piping primitives number
supports and they also number has also
built in support for numpy specifically
non pie raised so if you pass in dump I
raise number actually has specific
optimizations that it can do to numpy so
don't prime number work very well
together even stuff like strings it can
still be more efficient but generally
it's really just meant for primitive
numerical types and dense buffers of
numerical data and stuff like numb pine
that's kind of really what it's mainly
for you can also use over arbitrary
types and even specify your own more
complex structures for example of
structures that have a mixture of intz
and floats and things like that but
generally speaking is it's numerical
data is primarily what it's useful
so I said again would ask a question it
depends so yeah I mean that's a bit of a
vague answer so just to repeat the
question the question was wouldn't using
some kind of simple in-memory database
like for example SQL lights be faster
than using your operators in dump I so I
guess there's two things there the first
is it really depends you're depending on
the database implementation so yes it
might be faster it might not be faster
it really depends what you're doing
right if you're saying we're swimming a
bunch of numbers up in SQLite be faster
than say using numpy I'm actually unsure
that's the case because you have a bunch
of other overhead because your
communication with the database the
database is compiling a queries having
to do something if you're just having an
umpire do numpy dot some that's probably
going to be faster although I haven't
done any benchmarks so that's just
purely I guess at this point the second
thing is there's value in using stuff
like numpy and number so the second
question actually the second point a
response to that is more well why
wouldn't we just you see because if
python is is really slow then why will
you just let you see because that will
always be guaranteed to be the fastest
thing the reason why you want to use to
flatten umpire number it's not just
because it's fast but because it's in
line with or how you're writing the rest
of your code
it's Python code and so by doing it like
that you're making it more maintainable
more easier for developers to use and
things like that so I think the the
disadvantages using something like an
in-memory database because you're
expressing things in a different way
very fundamentally different way which
might not always be possible so for
example in number with the unvectorized
what operations they would be very
difficult to do in a database query for
example so you're kind of representing
the problem in a completely different
way by doing it with your relational
joins and selects and things like that
just for the purposes of speed up and so
what you find get with an umpire number
is that speed up but you also get the
the fact that it stays true to the
convention of - like it's just - code
right it's just a sequential Python code
so the
you understand yep yeah yet I agree I
think that's a good benchmark in fact I
think we're gonna test this makes us for
the next time I do this talk I'm gonna
have some appendix slides for that paper
questions is there a way for a new bar
to actually use tie pins ask a question
I don't know the answer that question I
don't think so the reason why I would
think not at least yet is because those
type hints inherently you can specify
types that aren't number supported types
so number has its own types in its
library like in 64 and all these other
native types whereas a typing of course
can be anything it could be like mapping
just record it or something like that so
all those types of things wouldn't be
you can't you can't guess the types of
those in your compiled machine code so I
would suspect not but it might be
possible might be some plug-in that
tries to do so thanks very person tation
by the way thank you and thus number
work with multiprocessing ah good
question so you you can't yet novel ways
to avoid processing basically so if you
have assuming of course your problem is
compute heavy and you're trying to
distribute say you've got four CPUs and
on your laptop or whatever and you're
using multi processing and you're
setting the process port to for you
could easily just have a number a jail
to mice function in number and have that
one of these different processes that's
totally possible today thank you
question over the back
what operations does number support just
the arithmetic ones or numpy or so so
arithmetic obviously general logic stuff
anything numpy related it tends to have
out-of-the-box support for it supports
operating on arbitrary strokes so if you
imagine some kind of composite type
where like a person where you have int
age and float average score or something
like that I don't know but you have some
kind of composite type it supports those
types of things that other blocks yeah
basically usually is anything that's IO
bound or anything that uses stuff like
generators or function callbacks and
things like that ten number tends to
fall down on because of you have this
notion because all those are executed in
Python using dynamic taking advantage of
the dynamically type nature of the
language whereas number can't do that so
really any area of attack operation a
logical operation and any operations on
plain old data structures you know just
basic densely packed data structures it
works fine with but anything else you
kind of lose some of the benefits one
thing I didn't mention as well is that
number doesn't it's not like I mentioned
that it's super super strict on what you
can do so number actually has a
different modes of compilation so the no
pipe in equals true means it must
compile to native machine code so
everything needs to be very basic you
can only do very restricted things in it
but if you don't specify that that
actually number has this notion of if
you just [ __ ] all the functions in
your library the things that it couldn't
optimize then it will just work optimize
it so it will just leave it so often
what you can't do is you can just see if
you actually everything in your in your
code just to see how curiosity if
actually everything in your code with no
Python equals false which means that it
will just won't error if it can't
compile it it will just leave it be the
regular Python function then you can see
if you get any speed-up whatsoever so
it's kind of a mix of both so what this
means is you can often have
you can just naively jit things and then
you can kind of opt you can benchmark
after that and profile and see which
things optimize them what and see what
things you might need to simplify I'm in
order to get there Python equals true Oh
question here no I just want you have a
question is there a big difference is
there any difference between using
tombow and seitan good question so we
actually siphon as well in in alpha so
the difference really with siphon and
number is that so for those who don't
know siphon is essentially almost like a
pre compilation step for Python code so
it's kind of like an enhanced and how to
- where there's extra syntax for
specifying statically typed things and
defining things in such a way that it's
compiled able to native code so the idea
is you write Python code and most of it
is just kind of regular - but you
specify you have these special keywords
where you can say you know define this
function with or to find this variable
with this type and things like that and
then just run syphon to compile all that
Python source code as native machine
instructions so not really no so you
won't really get any speed up the early
post potential reasons to really use
number over syphon so one issue we know
we've just found with syphon is it's
kind of infectious so you know if you
have some code resize and it means that
when you're deploying your code you
always need to meet your size and runs
so you've now added some complexity to
your build step and you're also just not
using regular - so that means any person
who comes onboard the project suddenly
they're having to know all these
different CP deaths and all these
different kind of sizing keywords
whereas number is a lot less invasive
rather than just save run siphon on a
bunch of pyx files I think that's the
right extension on these special siphon
code bases it's actually just regular -
and you can just specify specific
functions in one module which is all
normal pipe or all regular pipe and
apart from these - and it will just work
out the box so I think it's from a
performance perspective siphon would
probably arguably be even better because
it's forcing you to do everything
native machine code essentially but for
the for the routines that it counts it's
often not worth changing your whole
module or your or a large part of your
code base to use this there's basically
domain-specific version of Python and
just kind of isolating it to one or two
functions depends because I want to
figure out its life in there we reuse
that we like it thank you some last one
question okay well thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]